have sympathy with Nicola and Mark
clearly we're all against rape it's a
hideous accusation and allegation and a
hideous crime having said that what you
see in things like marker marks a
resilient man he was six weeks being
investigated over Christmas and New Year
the impact on him and his family must
have been enormous and the strain and
the trauma that's there it's almost we
do believe in an innocent till proven
guilty in this country but we know that
because of the trauma that people who
are accused of these things go through
it's an unusual punishment that they
have to go and they themselves
particularly and I'm talking
particularly and only in these areas
where people are not charged it's they
become the victim I mean if the
complaint appears to be that this is an
exceptional crime in as much as the
accuser has unlimited but the accused
doesn't yes and the thing that we find
is that people that are accused of
terrorism offense or child abuse they
are crimes that also have a stigma to
them rape isn't unique in that respect
but the stigma of reporting rate for a
rape victim is unique because a lot of
women are fearful of coming forward
because of cultural issues if you come
forward and report rape a lot of the
time you're the one that's seen as the
liar not just from the police but from
the wider community which you might be
of course well reported rates are the
I'm sorry there are rate of women are
falsely accuse or what was it what is
known as a false accusation and less
than two percent of all reported rapes
so the amount of report of false rape
allegations are so tiny but introducing
anonymity for men that charge was set
the anti rate movement back thirty years
is it the imbalance that annoys you I
mean if there wasn't an empty four
accusers would you be happy for it for
the accused to be no I I want anonymity
for the accusers for all the reasons
that Nicola knows which is that we want
to encourage people have been victims of
rape to come forward and one of the ways
they do that is by full knowledge that
throughout their entire life they remain
anonymous and as they wish to waive that
right and I think that's important Adam
but what I also think is important is
that police are allowed to investigate
something like
which they would have done over six
weeks found that there was not evidence
sufficient to take it any further and
decided after six weeks which is a
relatively short time to say that the
investigations over in something like
Paul Gambaccini z-- case it was a year
and for that year Paul didn't work now
Paul's not unique in that regard because
there have been other high-profile cases
least bail who haven't worked in other
things that no silly no no absolutely
and that's why I think that the issue of
bail which is being looked at is
something that desperately does need to
be looked at but all I want to do is to
bring in the Equality of it and it used
to be the case that prior to 1988 it was
anonymous for both sides in 1988 it was
decided to change it so that those who
are being accused were no longer
anonymous I think we've tried this
experiment long enough there is no
recognition absolutely no recognition
Adam of the impact that an investigation
high profile with a full glare of
publicity has on people what are the
advantages of naming someone who's
accused well the thing is and you know
it sounds reasonable to say let's not
name men unless they're charged but the
reality for reporting rape is it's one
of the hardest things you have to do
because automatically the police look
for reasons as to why you might be lying
as to rather as to why you're telling
the truth it's very very difficult to
get a rape charge to court even and a
lot of the time that police can only do
that if there is more than one victim so
if we're not going to name men until
they're charged it means that a lot of
other victims won't have the courage to
come forward if they see that somebody
has been named it often gives them the
courage to come again that is surely the
most telling reason at all these know
child abuse and yeah that encases
emergent accepted it's an important
aspect that more people come forward we
saw it with Stuart Hall and Rolf Harris
right so we witnessing that initially
the fact is that in cases like Paul
Gambaccini xand earmark pritchards and a
number of others nobody else comes
forward so they've gone this is I mean
as you Otto
justice is a rough process for anybody
who's accused of anything and even if
there goes far as facing trial yeah but
Adam if we can introduce a system that
has some sort of equity more equity in
it than is currently the case then that
needs to have
our my suggestion is I'll make one
suggestion here which is that the police
are able to go to a judge and say we
believe that anonymity should be lifted
in this particular case because and
we've got evidence as to why more people
will come forward you know if men
weren't named before they were charged
then none of us would know about what
Jimmy Savile had done when Stewart Hall
stood on the steps when he was first
charged when when he was charged with
the rape of one woman he sit on the
steps and the allegations he said was
spurious cruel callous and absolutely
untrue but because he had been named
other women came forward and he was
found guilty and in Rotherham girls were
going to the police and saying I have
been raped I'm being systematically
raped by numbers of men and they were
being told to go away and being told
that they would be charged some of them
were actually charged and were convicted
of harassment criminal damage being
drunk women are coming forward and
reporting rape and not being believed
and bringing anonymity and for men is
perpetuating this ridiculous myth I
think the majority of women like that I
think in the past Nicola there was a lot
of when people walked in that they were
instantly believable now that has
changed there's a lot more emphasis on
saying that automatically the police
believe an encourage more women Kato
shows that doesn't have all women should
come forward if they're happy but you
now have the advantage of having been
cleared yes as that's Mark Pritchard I
mean isn't that worth something as well
yeah but it's that's what I want to do
ask Nicola do you even understand the
trauma that something like Paul
Gascoigne Cliff Richard who hasn't even
been arrested chilly right I mean I mean
there are a number of cases out there
that I'm now clearly taking interest in
there was one Oxford Union student
president Ben Sullivan six weeks that he
had to go through enormous trauma never
mind the expense because there's expense
as soon as the clock starts ticking for
those who were accused and they don't
get their money back
I'm just asking - Claire do you
understand for a single second what it's
like for those people to go through that
accusation case really patronizing for
you to say do I even understand because
for anybody that's falsely accused of a
crime is horrific but with the greatest
of respect to everybody here being found
not guilty or not facing any charges is
completely different to a false rape
allegation and when a woman goes to the
police Andrew
courts rape and either the police closer
or the CPS closer or due to a fact that
a really poor prosecution is plays out
in court and they don't get justice can
you imagine living with that can you
imagine dealing with being raped and
knowing that the your eacute that the
person that raped you has walked free to
rape other women of course I have
sympathy for anybody that's falsely
accused of a crime but an acquittal is
whether you think it's worth going
through the trauma them and their
families going through thankful man if
we're talking about trying to secure
justice for rape victims you have to
look at what is better overall okay and
if you go to court and you're acquitted
you can get on with your life a woman
that is raped and doesn't get any
justice it's a lot harder a lot of us
speak from personal issues you seem less
like a walk-in absolutely just go
through a calling I said it so what Adam
I can't even begin Parker doesn't think
right for all your listeners out there
that you get a knock on the door top 70
and you're accused of rape just think
well it's like a family but it give me
answer all I'm asking before and we do
it but the issue is you are singling out
a particular crime has particular
accusation I mean no one whatever
they've done likes getting a knock on
the door so at 6:00 in the morning from
the police and most of those people can
be identified you know if they're
accused of theft or assault or you know
drunk driving or whatever they can be
identified so you have to make the case
as to why in this particular case I just
think that there's something special
about a sex allegation these days and
it's not just simply the Jimmy Savile
thing I think anybody who's accused of a
sexual crime there tends to be stigma
with it that even lingers post either
that no further action or indeed
acquittal it's one of those things in
you recognize that rape rape is a
hideous thing to be accused of it's a
hideous thing to be to to go through us
but we also find that when you have
reported right if you are if you don't
get any justice in any step of the
system you're the one that's looked at
as you made a false rape allegation you
made it up and that is that's what you
sould have to live with being raped and
then you have to live with it I have
women who've actually been sent to
prison yes absolutely and we believe
that some of those in miscarriages of
justice we're working to overturn those
because a lot of the media reports
things that
we aren't true and if you actually look
behind the scenes of what happens in
Cork
you think my God had if these women get
found guilty of making a false
allegation Gail share with Laila Ibrahim
you know we're working at the moment to
try and overturn their convictions
because we believe they miscarriages of
justice and of course as I've said Nigel
we have it sent every sympathy for
anybody that's falsely accused of a
crime but an acquittal is not the same
as a philosopher finding that day as a
parliamentarian do you think the law is
going to be changed on the show is this
a pretty long then no there needs to be
some consensus and prior to well 2010
all the parties were looking at it but
they just couldn't get agreement I'm
just thinking that in light of the
experience not just of Mark Pritchard
and myself but the number of other
high-profile cases that have now come
forward and
but eventually the Justice Secretary
will say come on let's just get equity
and package working over in 1988 well no
we hope not because it would be a
disaster because do we really believe
that the 94% of acquittals do we really
believe we'd all have to be very naive
to believe that 94%
okay well thank you very much indeed
thank you